so these hooks this four-step process
starts with a trigger to an action and a
reward and an investment so every hook
starts with a trigger a trigger prompts
the habit and we have these two types of
triggers an external trigger or an
internal trigger external triggers are
things in our environment that tell us
what to do next they give us some piece
of information click here by now a
friend telling you about this great new
app through word of mouth all examples
of external triggers these external
triggers prompt us to action that's the
habit itself open an app scroll through
Pinterest search on Google push the play
button on YouTube these are these
actions that we do with little or no
conscious thought that are these very
simple behaviors these very small
behaviors that that we do seeking a
reward which brings me to the third step
of the hook the reward phase is where
the users itch is scratched where they
get what they came for and yet there's a
bit of mystery around what they might
find next time they engage with the
product so it's not just a reward it
turns out that habit forming
technologies integrators called a
variable reward so this comes from the
classic work of BF Skinner the father of
operant conditioning Skinner found that
when he gave rewards to his pigeons in
these little boxes on a variable basis
so sometimes the pigeons would peck at
the disk they wouldn't receive a reward
the next time they would receive a
reward what Skinner observed was at the
rate of response a number of times these
pigeons pecked at the disk increased
when the reward was given on an
intermittent schedule of reinforcement
and so in all sorts of products that we
find most habit-forming most engaging we
find this bit of mystery this bit of
variability so searching and scrolling
and scrolling on a news feed or what
makes sports fun to watch is the
uncertainty of what will our team win
the game or what makes for a great TV
show or movie right the uncertainty
about how the happy ending is going to
unwind all that these are examples of
variable rewards and finally the
investment phase the last step of the
hook the investment phase is where the
user is prompted to put something into
the product to invest in the product in
anticipation of a future benefit so the
purpose of investments
is to increase the likelihood of the
next pass that's what the investment
phase is for and it does this in two
ways the investments load the next
trigger so loading the next trigger an
example that would be when I send
someone a message on whatsapp I don't
get any immediate rewards right there's
no there's no leaderboards there's no
badges there's no points nothing really
happens what I'm doing is I'm loading
the next trigger because I'm likely to
get a reply and that reply comes coupled
with an external trigger hey here's a
message from your friend which prompts
me to use the hook once again the second
way that investments increase the
likelihood of the next pass is by
storing value and this is a big deal
storing value is when the product gets
better and better with use it
appreciates in value and it does this by
storing data followers reputation
content right anything that I'm putting
into the app that gets better and better
over time and so it's through successive
cycles through these hooks trigger
action reward investment that now an
association is built with that second
type of trigger member i told you there
was two types of triggers external
triggers and internal triggers the
internal trigger is the are these things
in our life that prompt us to action
like a place a situation or routine a
certain person and most frequently
emotions that prompt us to do this next
action this next habit with little or no
conscious thought but without any
explicit information so over time
through successive cycles through these
hooks now we use the product not with a
message that tells us hate click here
but with a need exactly we internally
trigger ourselves we have these
associations so I'm lonely I check
facebook I'm uncertain I google I'm
bored and I'm on youtube or reddit or
checking stock prices or sports scores
right we do these things instantaneously
because of these success successive
cycles through these hooks